I've mentioned before there are two
ways to add the constraints to our
record button.
There's another way if you don't want to
use the align button I’ve shown you
previously.
This is just to show you another way to
accomplish the same auto layout task,
you don't have to do this step.
First, I’m going to delete these two
constraints by highlighting them and
pressing the delete key.
Then, with the record button selected,
I'm going to hold down the control key,
and drag diagonally here into the view.
Now if I hold down the shift key
I can select center horizontally,
center vertically in container, and
then press the add constraints button.
This adds the exact same constraints
we did earlier using the align button.
I know this may seem like a bit of work
just to start understanding auto layout
and to get the button to be in
the center of the screen, but
as the saying goes you have to
learn to crawl before you can walk.
In the next section we're going to
wire up our button to the code in
the viewcontroller.swift file and make
the record button actually do something.